[Music]
have you ever heard of a guy named
peacemaker no
he is a trained killer
we've got trouble with that maniac
go what are you waiting for that thing
better not crap back there yeah i'll
strain an eagle dude that without
stealing its soul
hey dad
it's a kind of rough go from the daily
dad you don't say somebody shot me a
building fell on me you let somebody
shoot you it's not inviting him to come
shoot me dad
i thought you're in prison for life i
work for the government post office do
you think they let me out of prison to
deliver mail i don't know it's the first
government job i could think of i killed
people for okay
this task force doesn't officially exist
which leaves us on our own we call our
targets butterflies they are a serious
threat to the safety of american
citizens
there's something weird going on you
think me and vigilante are too stupid to
notice hey everyone which one's me and
which one's easily okay you're half
right but you score 50 of the test at
school what do you get
school isn't my bag it's for dorks
[Music]
that guy's a clown but there's something
about him that's
sad
is he a target in sight peacemaker take
him out even the kids yes terminate them
immediately
take the socks
he told me to kill kids he didn't say
why because right now the world needs
the son of a [ __ ]
you're the only one i got
i thought you loved peace no matter how
many men women and children you needed
to kill to get it
i don't know i think i'm having feelings
about things
[Music]
dad maybe i'm a grower not a shower what
an individual you don't like and then
you learn to like you're comparing
yourself to a chode not a bad way your
dad is not a good man still family my
advice cut it out with the introspection
the mind is a den of scorpions better
left running from not towards
[Applause]
[Music]
we just got shut you haven't been shut
[Music]
two jerks and costumes and a couple of
rejects
it's like a real team out there
russian tank shell why not just the
grenade grenade blows up like two people
how many people does this blow up i
don't know i invented it this morning
what
[Music]
eat peace [ __ ]
[Music]
you